when building a successful e-commerce
business like the first thing wait wait
you have to realize is that the best
customer is a customer who who keeps
coming back and so like as we look at
teespring the people like you do really
well on our platform or people who
who've been able to build a brand with
their buyers on T spring and been able
to like bring them back over and over
and over again to be able to purchase
more and more products and the best
thing what you can do to attach li ang
for that is really invest in customer
service and really invest in in sort of
answering answering any questions might
your customers have on in kind of really
feeling really making making your
customers feel that that you as the kind
of e-commerce platform or like as a
product owner and actually care about
what they want and so like it's really
easy to kind of think about all right
let's like optimize optimize the
purchase flow let's kind of like cut
costs where we can let's not for the
cheapest price but at the end of the day
what's going to bring that buyer back
again is the customer service in the
actual intend experience right you offer
them